Creamfields like Korean people spicy but
sweet hot and meaty so I know that if
you live in Los Angeles you need to eat
Korean barbeque if you're a fun person
and I've not done it yet so maybe I'm
not a fun person Oh what's up why have
you gone I've heard about Korean
barbecue and I've never tried it
I'm a little weary of meats that I don't
know of why I add some Korean barbecue
in my day and it's good as [ __ ] I've not
met one person I've introduced green
barbecue who has not fell in love with
it that's a lot of pressure for me yeah
all right I'm ready
I'm ready for it I've heard of kimchi
but I don't know what that is so kimchi
is the staple side dish in Korea I think
the best way to put it for people who
don't know Korean food is it's like
spicy pickles I think this one's gonna
be spicy I know you don't like spicy you
like spicy yes smell is just like hello
good morning wake up [ __ ] okay now one
thing people don't know is when you go
to a Korean restaurant they give you
something called banh Chung we're just
like the collection of side dishes so
every time you go to Korean restaurant
you get a whole slew of Bashan that's
free and replenishable I don't know how
I feel about it I don't understand it
kimchi is delicious
but your breath suffers for weeks yeah
I'm good on that note you don't like
kimchi then I don't like you haha all
right what's next
I'm gonna butcher the name below gee
we're lucky is one of the staple Korean
barbecues generally any kind of beef
usually flank I would say well it's
similar to brisket the way it's cooked
in the way it's marinated that process
gives it this like really deep flavor
mmm that's good nice pretty good it's
delicious
so like thin kind of melts in your mouth
but you need some barbecue sauce on it
so galbi has a similar marinade but it's
a different cut and it's the prized cut
it's the short rib is it inappropriate
to just pick it up oh that's push off
this way okay but I feel like you can
just grab it by the like thing and just
like you can eat it with your hands too
but you're doing it straight up like
Korean a dish you style like older
Korean guy I can be an older for you
guys oh oh it's ah that is amazing like
melt in your mouth
wow that's really chowder no it's really
good I could eat this for the rest of my
life this is a little different cuz it's
already cooked but you usually are part
of the cooking process which is always
nice I would definitely go to like a
real
have it cooked in front of me I think
that would be fun people act like it's a
fun and cool experience to get to cook
your own food if I wanted to cook my own
food I do that huh well that's why
people go in big groups you want to be
my date
almir Korean barbecue date kimchi in my
belly got kimchi on my face if you don't
like kimchi you're a Korean disgrace mmm
that was great yeah you've been sitting
on that one for a while pretty much yeah
what I think about every time I do
kimchi